hey we're the try guys that we're in
Miami I'm he's known for its beautiful
beaches amazing food sometimes the
ladies don't wear tops here when I think
South Beach I think like the Kiwis Will
Smith hot ladies with hot things money
fast cars cocaine basically the opening
credits of Miami Vice South Beach is
like a tiny tiny bit of Miami what's the
real Miami for me Miami is Cuban culture
Little Havana Calle Ocho Versailles is
gazebo
welcome to Little Havana our goal today
is to explore Miami Cuban culture
through four categories food ensuring
fashion tradition and nightlife the try
guys are now the travel guide as we
explore Miami's Cuban culture
[Music]
Miami has the largest Cuban population
in America studied Spanish growing up
but I don't think I've ever eaten Cuban
food you can culture they dress it's
sick Wyatt linens why a bit that's why I
have wife Ohio ADA is customary Cuban
dress shirt would you say that I'm
dressed Cuban right now no we have to
change we have to put the classical of
the Kulin person
hi I'm Fidelis
I own the Havana collection in Little
Havana Southwest 8th Street Miami what
you're wearing is a four pocket Cuban
boy Aveda this goes back 60 years into
Cuba we're old gentleman actually came
and asked his wife to make him a shirt
so he can go and pick more boy out
what's the most traditional way better
here okay we're going to show you the
for package conditioner Miami Sun and
you wear with the panama hats in your
Cuban cigar you ready kozak I found the
things little bit you wait there the
woman's right here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey yeah I like it I'm ready to be an
extra in it Indiana Jones film I like I
look incredible you look stunning
Ned you look so dead right now I think I
look like a CIA's I believe they have
four pockets I got like a cookie in here
and another cookie in here and then a
third cookie right here you can put
anything in there before with cigars and
our cellphones
I gotta have four cell phones I've never
felt this much air between the fabric my
body reason why they wear the linen is
because it breathes it's like wearing
sweatpants but they're dressy it's so
comfortable look at after a few drinks
everybody can dance
you're like I look like a cabana boy it
is soon mojito know anything about the
chest hair is this too much I think you
have a future oh yeah should try to
cover up a little more because you
haven't no no Julia do you have one
element of jewelry are you married I am
I'm sorry to hear what kind of Cuban guy
would I be do you think a single one
thanks so much for showing us this yeah
you guys look great appreciate it you'll
have a good evening tonight oh I'm
excited I like to eat what am I supposed
to eat there Boston ethos which are
Cuban pastries and there's a castle big
wala yá ricci of Central America it's
like that brute that a lot of people
have but like Americans don't ever try
it everything is glazed and covered in
sugar really hope I don't stain my white
all white a tire like very sticky you
touch it and it's just sticks right to
eat berries are pretty sticky it's like
so looks
oh good my mouth just had food sex like
raspberries that are sweet but also tart
how would you did for breakfast every
day rotten cheese pastry I hope it
doesn't burst all over my blouse
don't call it a blouse impulse in your
mouth but there's like a better version
of a pop-tart though it's just rude oh
thank you buck
so what are some things we have to do on
kyocho there are a bunch of Cubans
playing dominoes this is the infamous of
Domino of markets every day there's a
lot of people here old Cuban men
mastering those that's all
jazz
so here's how you play each player is
dealt seven dominoes players take turns
adding a domino to the table that
matches the dots on either of the two
ends they're really intense so be wary
we can play you have to take one from
here here
No
if a player can't play they knock the
table to pass
I gotta say by the way you're describing
old Cuban men are way nicer than old
white men yeah the first person to play
all of their dominoes wins so if one of
us beats an old Cuban man and Domino's
all the restaurants is there a place
that we should eat besides Versailles is
the best Cuban restaurant in Miami
I thought Versailles was French you know
it is but for some reason the Cubans
have just taken it so it's ours now in
Miami people are loving
your beaumont say so it smells like a
red pill makes its Marty this is like a
thermo it's the number one beer for
Ironman
the only
you know what these are called moolah
the way it all worked together it's lady
it's vinegary so worker discipline
tastes like a banana peel around already
what are they cooking it in gold fried
pork tongue it's like on the texture of
short herbs inside
oxtail stew degrees oh yeah huh that
means old clothing yeah how would we
want to eat that it's delish it's
amazing it's shredded beef in like this
really great marinade
[Music]
no clothing at all you know
[Music]
Oh
speechless I can't I need a can I have a
moment key guys we cannot orgasm in
public
to do an orgasm to the table
we're oversized but there has this kind
of food it's all incredible comes from
that's like warm and special
really make the container
[Music]
young
whenever you hear cigar it's synonymous
with Cuban cigar why is that
I don't smoke cigars but it's a whole
thing it's like a ritual it's like
something you do have family gatherings
I don't like having a drink South
Florida is very rich and the history of
tobacco it dates back to the 1830s so do
they make cigars in Miami
there are cigar factories in Miami
they're hand rolled and it's like super
technical
there's 330 steps I'm harvesting all the
way to consumers the three major pillars
are daily hello the visto with the
Cubans called bolado in the second the
blend of those leaves is what comes out
different cigars whether you have a
medium or full body cigar taste a sort
of brazen raisiny flavor it's not as
easy as it sounds rolling cigars 100%
handmade nothing machine the only
machines that do is to cut them to press
our Cuban hands better stupid little Jew
hands
[Music]
this is the person of the filler and you
see how's your position in the center of
the to leaf you have to do that if not
your cigars gonna be burning an uneven
feeling real confident I'm a pretty good
at rolling things
three two one chop that dick kind of can
I should do it though right okay nailed
it oh it's two pieces oh yeah that's
firm that's the cigar ladies and
gentlemen we Beneatha SS cigar s lo
mejor cigar que su as well and to be
back the cigars round one and looks like
Ned has a little bit of that too I'm
Zack will determine down when it gets
press and see how it looks when it's
already had the shape and she says wait
for the verdict
there's the Cuban coffee Cuban coffee
why is it is it not just coffee
I mean coffee is just crazy strong crazy
crazy strong it's like a thing you do
with family like it's meant to be
enjoyed
about how Eugene yeah I don't understand
the words it I just don't see how
there's
oh my god oh my god oh that's so slow
that was not expecting that I can tell
it's really strong but it's so sweet
it's like really good dark chocolate
that's been lightly sweet my face is
tingling yeah [ __ ] right now I want to
have five of these every meal we don't
know one of these you know seriously cuz
I'm almost done with my tiny cup [ __ ]
PLA should be in New York should be
everywhere a plus plus plus plus plus
plus tiny coffee big flavor back at the
cigar factory Keith in Eugene are gonna
take our pressed filler and wrap it to
be a finished product these are like the
inside of the hotdog and that's a casing
the little knife tool that's called
looked over at them that's how you cut
it it's kind of like rolling sushi yeah
this is just arts and crafts I
understand this entirely super-competent
I could take over the world I could take
over all Miami's with the this year
amount of pure amount of Kaposi know
that the - he had no problem this is way
tougher than I thought it'd be just to
cut the first line Robertson Nomad that
their cappuccino and she can't stop
[ __ ] out oh yeah
no you honey did I do it there's okay oh
then you push it in she's doing all the
work for everyone
we're merely her puppets I do feel I
like to be more
she's my Patrick Swayze I think I'm done
I'm actually pretty confident my cigar
now his looks like it's got some angles
in it we got to do now is we have to
take our cigars to a cigar master of 50
years
who's going to basically appraise who
has the better
amateur cigar
[Music]
[Music]
that's a winner right there Wow what a
roller coaster this has been I am better
than eugene at pretty much everything in
this video I look better I roll better I
eat better I feel better if it's our
baby I appreciated how much artisan [ __ ]
goes into making just a single cigar you
know I don't think the world is ready
for my cigars and that's fine most of
the best art in the world scared people
at first to leave cigar rollers do it
like that like theme I understand why
these are so special and expensive you
know yeah you want to smoke a cigar you
lit it through the head we're supposed
to look what it is favoring the flavors
and I can taste the same spice that like
tickle my nose yeah she doesn't feel
very expensive we typically do it when
we're celebrating something for like the
birth of a child and you're going away
nice meal this makes sense yeah yeah
yeah
suave
this is all great in all most
importantly how do Cubans [ __ ] party
[ __ ] party or [ __ ] party
I would wouldn't mind either and they're
one of the same you should go to the
other miss food colitis which is an arts
and culture festival and
oh I need a necklace
dominoe I feel like this can wait for
what yeah I don't
like this magnet
I love the colors
very artistic
and I
some of them have been here
so bad here and they
you would never know that anything bad
had happened to them even though a lot
of these people had fled their countries
they're still happy
Miami or anywhere
whole like neighborhood just turns into
this massive party like there's a lot of
food and drink and people just dancing
all over the place like in the streets
and stuff it's a the streets yeah yeah
totally where else are you gonna dance
they did
[Music]
I guess on a scale of one to ten how
hard to the people of Miami party off
the scale
insane every summer a street party gone
we are getting hot dancers
Cuban Americans are extremely proud
they love to cook and love to be with
family and that's really what matters
your family wherever you go so once
you're there for a little bit you'll
become kind of Cuban by the end of it
and have a little piece of that with you
forever so we might become human al you
might
I love whispering
then you have to plan a vacation no I'll
just go where the locals go is the most
loving positive place I've ever paid
it's rare that you have people who just
walk up to you with open arms and say
hey your family let's party it's kind of
amazing that there's so many of those
like strong people in Miami where like
their grandparents came or that her
parents came from Cuba and they kind of
left everything and they started a new
Miami story is the American story they
didn't wait for to feel like it was home
they like made it their home I think
it's really easy to come to the city and
just go to the tourist location a little
bit before the Cuban immigration Miami
was nothing compared to what it is now
you're in the north of South America
yeah you're in northern Cuba
I can't sum up Miami in a same sentence
it is
to come out here and experience it for
yourself
[Music]
[Music]